segundo día de protestas en Paraguay lo
simpatizantes de paraguayo Cuba es el
tercer colocado en la disputa electoral
protestan contra un supuesto fraude
electoral estamos en las inmediaciones
del tribunal superior de justicia
electoral Y esto es lo que nos dicen los
manifestantes
[Aplausos]
no nos sentimos identificados con el
narcotráfico viva el Paraguay soberano
[Aplausos]
lo que queremos conseguir es una
elección limpia hace más de 80 años nos
encontramos en esta situación todos los
jóvenes que estamos aquí estamos Porque
necesitamos un verdadero cambio
cambiaron completamente las elecciones
no vendieron
[Música]
en toda la región del tribunal superior
de justicia electoral hay mucha policía
para evitar enfrentamientos y problemas
hoy el jefe de la misión de observadores
electorales de la Unión Europea dijo que
descarta tajantemente que hubo un fraude
electoral habrá que ver si en los
próximos días siguen las protestas o si
los ánimos se APA